Jasmina and Venizelos have reached a
decision they want to live without
plastic it pollutes the environment and
gradually enters the food chain that's
dangerous to humans as well as animals
there's a Llosa's want to better protect
themselves against the toxic chemicals
contained in plastic they are especially
worried about the danger to their
children but plastic is now an integral
part of our lives will they be able to
avoid it completely take ordinary
plastic toothbrushes the first thing we
put in our mouths in the morning is pure
plastic and we've also been thinking
about toothpaste this is toothpaste
without fluoride because we don't want
fluoride but it's in a plastic tube so
we're going to switch to bamboo brushes
and make the toothpaste ourselves that's
fairly easy with coconut oil baking soda
xylitol also known as birch sugar and
whiting chocolate ingredients Yasmine
easily found either online or in her
health food store they're also making
their own shower gel the first step is
braiding curd soap with the help of
four-year-old Mina and one-year-old
Arnaud that way they can avoid the
plastic containers used for shower gels
and shampoos
okay so Mina what did we write down we
need 50 grams for the shower gel the
soap is dissolving it's not appealing at
all
looks more like cocoa well we'll see now
we'll pour it in would she wash with it
I have no qualms about it
we usually shower with all sorts of gels
without knowing their ingredients but I
do know this one so I'll definitely try
it the ingredients include apple teeth
essential oils and soap conventional
shower gels often contain chemicals such
as propylene glycol which makes the skin
more permeable to other ingredients
they're homemade shower gel gets put
into what else an old plastic container
but reusing it is better than throwing
it away you can put that in step 2
getting rid of all the other plastic
there are no you can put something into
the whole drawer is full of plastic the
Zelo says have read a lot on the subject
many studies provide evidence that
plastic components can cause cancer and
infertility if they get into the body
after smile but Mina's not keen on
clearing away her plastic toys so her
mother does it for her she might need
some persuading you know let's clear
that away too then the next time you
have a bath you can play with the
stainless steel bottles or spoons that
at least there are alternatives for bath
toys that's not true of other household
items I love this vacuum cleaner it's a
vacuum and a mop still it has to go from
now on they'll be sweeping the celos
family lives in my ting in a small town
in provincial Bavaria in large German
cities a few supermarkets avoid stocking
items in disposable packaging Benny
Salus would like something like that in
writing
but it's not that we're actively
preaching it that's not what we're doing
now
the next challenge plastic free grocery
shopping
this is what bothers us this is the
organic section but everything's wrapped
in plastic apples peppers kiwi fruit
it's all in plastic also bye jars like
this in the supermarket applesauce and
jars those are all tetra Paks I really
have to search
here's rice and millet I'd buy it but
they're also wrapped in plastic I'll see
if I can find some other rice this is
the only one of all the brand surprise
that isn't wrapped in plastic it's loose
the others that are in boxes are in
plastic bags for cooking and this is the
only one I can find in a plain box Mady
rice fortunately flour is in paper yes
means a low stinks cutting down on
plastic packaging would be a major step
forward packaging makes up around a
third of the plastic the world uses
Venizelos is a successful software
developer he too is skeptical about
plastic but their weekly shopping isn't
finished yet and Beni has cheated he's
bought wood for the fireplace even
though it's in a plastic sack back home
Yasmine has a client she advises women
on cloth diapers and she's made her
convictions for profession she shows
other parents how to move away from the
disposable ones but even the cloth
version needs a plastic outer covering
though it doesn't come into contact with
the baby's skin I don't think the aim is
to do completely without plastic it's
about awareness and the fact that
they're reusable that's why I think the
plastic
is okay here her client says she'll try
them out at least this a Llosa started
rethinking their attitudes when they had
Meena their first child we always wanted
to have only wooden toys as presents but
we kept them given plastic but they put
all this stuff in their mouths and you
start noticing everything that contains
plastic the next step
new dishes for the children glossy
packed in plastic great you want to buy
plastic free items and they're wrapped
in plastic the new dishes are made of
bamboo you can even put them in the
dishwasher
but finding them wasn't easy many brands
failed consumer tests because they
contained two toxic chemical the
manufacturer of these says they're safe
because they haven't finished their
weekly shopping Yasmine has to go out
again this time to the market
she's not the only one there who's
trying to avoid plastic why does this
woman brought her own bag because it's
not plastic it's organic I just heard
you talking about fetching milk with a
can that really happened I can still
remember it most young people just don't
know how things used to be
I actually remember taking a can to
fetch a liter of milk with my grade out
maybe that's why I want to pass on my
awareness to my children of course if it
hadn't been for their plastic free
project the sailors family could have
found everything at the supermarket
avoiding plastic isn't for days when
you're in a hurry
in the evening the shower gel and
shampoo will get put to the test they
can still drink the water that's the
most important thing now there's just
rye flour from the home made shampoo in
the bath water
the army will be found and what about
the toothpaste
Cimino says she doesn't like it and
asked for something else well my mother
explains that's all they have right now
Yasmine does use the hairdryer keeping
bath time completely plastic free just
isn't going to work time for supper
and some reflection they've held out for
three days without plastic it's almost
impossible to be perfectly honest these
days with what's on offer whether you
live in the country or the city you
don't have enough alternatives to make
it work it's actually harder than you
think with the children especially when
shopping but you can be more aware I
know I don't want to do without a vacuum
cleaner because the children drop rice
when they're eating I drop things it
doesn't matter who or what and even
though the vacuum cleaner is made of
plastic I won't give it up
even though they can't avoid it entirely
the Salus family now wants to try to
live with his little plastic as possible
because for the sake of their children's
future